my name is mathias
i'm going to talk to you about graphs
but before i get to that point i want to
start with a story that
starts way way back as a teenager
i read a book about a teenage boy who
found himself
into all kinds of adventurous mysteries
where he had to solve a bunch of puzzles
in order to figure out what was going on
in his village
it was kind of like a sherlock's
sherlock holmes but for kids and without
that
superpower intelligence he was a smart
boy no doubt but he was just
above average smart however he did have
a tool
and that was a book it was a magical
book
that his father had given to him just
before he disappeared
and the boy took notes diligently in
this book writing down
every piece of information that he
thought would be useful later on
and then when he was confronted with a
puzzle some sort of cipher or code word
something he had to come up with
he would take the book drop it into the
palm of his hand it would open at the
page where he had written down the
information that he needed
in order to figure out what to do next
i thought that was a genius idea i
wanted to have that book
in particular in school i want to have
that book
see my my memory is pretty bad i mean
i'm doing well with numbers but when it
comes to names like names of places
people events it's just horrible i mean
it just completely escapes me
when the teacher puts you on the spot
and says hey you go name
the four bones and the human inner ear
i'm like
i have no clue i think it's pretty cool
how it works but i don't know what the
bones are called
nor did i really think that was very
important so
i wanted to to have that book now i
didn't have a magical book my father
never disappeared
so i stole one of the notebooks out of
his drawer and started taking notes
myself
i was kind of over ambitious at first
writing down every single thing that
happened to me which was socially very
awkward so i i toned that back a little
bit
and uh and you know kept writing notes
however it was then that i realized what
the real magic was all about it wasn't
that the book
seemingly had an infinite number of
pages where he could write stuff on
it was that it would always open at the
exact right page
see when you write notes you write them
and then they're somewhere but you never
find them again
and that's exactly what happened to me i
would write notes but i would never find
what i was actually looking for
and so i kind of gave up on that whole
idea for a little bit
i figured i should should find a subject
that had the highest thinking to
memorization ratio so i ended up
studying mathematics but
i never could really let go of that idea
of the the magic
book and i figured man there should be a
way that we can build a tool or
something
that that does that so that we can
finally get rid of having to memorize
stuff
right useless stuff mostly and so i
figured the best
discipline or the best skill set that
would enable me to do that was probably
computer science so i switched over from
mathematics
to computer science now
i have to burst the bubble right up
front i never
actually build a magical book or i
actually haven't built it
yet hopefully but it was a quite
interesting journey
thus far in the journey that i want to
talk to you about today
because i think it helped me appreciate
what that problem was really about as a
later on it was called
contextual information retrieval and i
learned a lot about the problem but more
importantly about that class of problems
and i think that would be very useful um
down the road in the future
as we're more and more confronted with
this class of problems
so when i switched over from mathematics
to computer science went to grad school
for computer science
i was generally pointed in the direction
of artificial intelligence machine
learning natural
natural language processing information
retrieval
so the lines between those are pretty
blurry but that seemed to be sort of
the area that i wanted to get into in
order to solve that problem and build
the magical book
when i looked at those i was like holy
cow they have done
so much research on that already right
that's like kind of the grass cool shock
when you go and you're like wow every
single problem has already been solved
i'm screwed but
then again it's like well they've done
all this great work
but here we are and we're still using
keyword search
plus plus for information retrieval so
what's going on why why haven't we done
a lot better why haven't we built this
intelligent machine yet that allows us
to do all these cool things
and most importantly not having to
memorize anything
i think retrospectively there are two
reasons for that
that i want to talk about the first
reason being
that in artificial intelligence machine
learning or those disciplines
you tend to work with abstractions
you tend to model the world we're all
familiar with that i mean
everybody who has ever touched a program
or ever written a program knows that
what you're essentially doing is you're
trying to find abstraction for the world
a representation for the world and when
you do so
you you're basically making some
assumptions about how you want to
represent things
now until though until we have reached
that point that people
call the singularity and here it's
coming
until we have reached that point there's
still
humans in front of that machine that
need to interact with it
and whether it's formal logical
languages and ai
or the vectors that machine learning
appreciates
it's still the case that for us humans
we have a different way of thinking
about it
and so i think the first thing that that
started to sort of daunt on me was that
we needed a way to better enable humans
to interact with these things
that we're building and so looking at
neuroscience one of the things that i
found was that
in neuroscience people have found out
that humans think associatively
all right that's probably not news to
anybody here the way we think about
things the way we store things in our
brain is associatively
so things like associations we are very
familiar with
we store things within context that's
why we are so
excellent at contextual retrieval and
contextual reasoning
however in computers we don't do that
and i want to sort of
you know do a little experiment here
since we have a lot of humans in the
room i figure
we do a little experiments to
demonstrate that and i brought two
queries that i i want you guys to have a
look at
the first question here is what is the
name of and the highest degree earned
by the wife of the current president of
the united states of america
anybody know
exactly michelle obama and she has a jd
now that took this gentleman really a
couple hundred milliseconds at most
plus he had to read the question so that
puts him at an unfair disadvantage
compared to computer
but let's look at this from a computer
because what's really impressive is that
he just solved
a four-way joint
yeah i hear a lot of pain in that
laughter because anybody who has tried
to solve four-way joints on large tables
knows how painful that can be
how much tuning has to go into this
right i don't think he tuned i hope you
didn't take any drugs this morning
but the point is
if you try to do this on a relational
machine assuming you have a table of all
humans in the world of all presidents of
all countries of all the degrees that
these people earned
you have a hell of a job to do trying to
optimize that thing
yet here we are here we have somebody
who has a brain that operates on
just a merely 20 watts and he did that
just like that
all right let's zoom it let's do a
different query and this time i'm going
to take a little easier on you guys
um because i don't want to wear you out
so let's let's look at this one what is
the average term length of those
presidents of the united states that
took office in the 1980s or later
two in years and years
seven years seven years
six eight
anybody else
wow so now we're doing binary search
that's what we're gonna
um it's actually it's actually
6.6 guys
and it was a stupid simple one-way joint
what's going on
the point of this exercise is really to
show that
while this query is really easy for a
relational database or a tabular
database
it turns out to be quite difficult for
humans and the other way around
the query that we just looked at which
is quite difficult for machines in
particular at scale
turns out to be pretty easy for us so
somehow there's something going on there
seems to be some sort of an impedance
mismatch between the two
and that's really the point of this
exercises is to point that out that the
way the abstractions we have
chosen to represent our data are not
very natural to us humans
right i mean if i look at my database
class all we ever talked about really
was relational databases so that was the
world fuzz that's how we thought about
data right there was really
nothing else i mean there was sort of
this brief history on databases kind of
thing like
look what those guys did and now we have
found the golden solution which is
relational database and we're going to
stick with that ever after
but the thing is for humans that doesn't
seem to be the case we store things
associatively and a representation that
seems to make a lot more sense
to humans is that of a graph that seems
to be a lot
closer to the way that we intuitively
think
about information the way that we
represent information in our head
now we use neurons and axons and
dendrites and all these things that's
our hardware
but at the abstraction at the
representation layer this seems to be
awfully close
to what's going on in our head and seems
to be a much
better representation to bridge the
impedance mismatch
that is going on here now for those of
you who aren't familiar with
with graphs and it's really more or less
the fault of our
you know our education we really don't
talk about them that much
you might have to do a minimum spanning
tree here and there but that's about it
a graph at the core really only consists
of of
two atomic elements and those are
vertices and edges
vertices in this particular
representation are shown as circles
and edges are shown as arcs between
those circles edges are directed to
indicate the directionality so for
instance we have an edge
between barack obama and the united
states of america
labeled president to indicate that
barack obama
is indeed the president of the united
states furthermore vertices and edges
both have properties on them those
indicated by these
white boxes properties decorate vertices
and edges to give them more meaning for
instance the president edge that i just
indicated
has a box on it that says he was
president from
2008 and the until box is empty
because he's still in office and
therefore still the president of the
united states
for previous presidents we have an until
date indicating that they are no longer
president of the united states there are
further family relationships encoded in
this graph like spout and
spouse and father as you can see and we
have uh
captured the degrees that michelle obama
has earned in her career
now with that representation once you
get used to it
it's actually quite quite natural it's a
very expressive representation for the
kinds of information that we're
typically confronted with
because it allows us to to have an
arbitrary set of elements or entities
represented as vertices and then capture
any kind of relationship
that might exist between those by edges
which makes it very flexible
it also gives rise so those this is on
the representation side it also gives
rise to means of querying this data
or analyzing this data that is much more
natural to our associative way of
thinking
and this graphical way of representing
data
the query language that i want to talk
here about today is called gremlin
and we're going to look at the very same
query that this gentleman up front just
so eloquently solved
and that is that of you know who is uh
who's michelle obama and what's her
highest degree
and you can see that in a graph it
actually
operates like you would think about it
associatively
we start with the united states of
america we traverse out so this is g
dot uppercase v the language you know is
probably new to most people in the room
but i think after you stare at it for a
little while you get
an intuitive hang of it we start with a
graph g so we have
an identifier for the graph then we say
give me all the vertices of that graph
that's uppercase v
but i only want to have those where the
country name is the united states of
america
so i'm restricting my initial vertex set
which init which then boils down to an
index retrieval on the graph
then i have identified the vertex usa
which is all the way to the left up here
and starting from that vertex i then
start to traverse
so what i say within e is that i want
all in
edges that are labeled president and
then
does not have an until date right so
that thereby i identify all edges that
indicate current presence of the united
states
i then retrieve the outgoing vertex so
the vertex at the other end of that edge
which is barack obama
i then say who is barge obama's spouse
following the spouse edge in the out
direction
i indicate that to be my variable x
which i can then later use to either
further process it or retrieve it
and then i say from that point on i want
to follow the
the degree edges so i want to look at
all the degrees that michelle obama
earned
following the out edges according to the
degree label
i want to retrieve the highest one since
i have implicitly ordered those i just
have to retrieve the first
select that as y and then get its name
to determine that it's a euros doctor
so you can see how this retrieval here
doesn't use any joins for once but
secondly also really
mirrors the way that you would
internally think about it
right if you follow your steps and it's
actually quite a funny exercise if you
come up with an answer to something to
then go back late and see how did i
actually get to that point
if you follow your steps trace your
steps you would probably find that you
did
something similar along to this you did
some sort of associative
walk on the graph that makes graphs
very natural for representing data and
in particular in those situations where
the ultimate customer your ultimate user
is
actually a human being the impedance
mass match is much much
smaller so that was number one
the impedance mismatch the fact that we
at the end of the day
will be interacting with humans when we
build systems
and we better come up with a way of
doing it in such a way that it's easy
for humans to grasp what's going on
there's a second thing going on here and
that is that with problems like
contextual information retrieval we see
what ends up happening is that
when you look at the different
disciplines so going back to the problem
definition go
looking at the different disciplines all
of them have their favorite approach
to looking at the problem an artificial
intelligence is typically about
some sort of logical language that you
want to represent the problem in
the nice thing about logical language is
once you're in a logical language you
have you know powerful tools like
inference deduction induction depending
on what your
favorite logical language is and you can
do use those
to arrive at conclusions if you're more
into machine learning your
abstraction tends to be the vector you
want to vectorize everything because
once the thing is a vector
you can do pretty much anything to it
you can drop it into
your favorite machine learning toolbox
and go to town on it
right so people tend to have these
abstractions that they like to represent
data in
now with any representation or
abstraction what ends up happening it's
a it's a
lossy process right when you go from
reality to model when you go from
reality to abstraction
you lose something in the process and
that's perfectly acceptable that's
perfectly fine that's what we have to
deal with on a daily basis
as long as the result is still somewhat
good enough right
you want to be close enough to reality
so that the analysis that you do
and the results that you come up with
are still meaningful to the problem that
you're trying to solve
so with that i found that for some
problems the problem is that that
abstraction tends to be too loose
it tends to not capture what is the
essence of the problem
and in that process losing the essence
and thereby your ability to effectively
solve the problem
now what is that class of problems well
luckily i went to grad school at a time
where a new discipline just
emerged and that discipline is called
network science
it was driven by researchers from very
many domains from
sociology biology so um computer
science a lot of physicists were in the
mix and they were driven
by their desire to understand what
seemed to be hopelessly chaotic or
complex
systems right the study of complex
systems
had made a great jump since we had the
event the data
available to actually analyze them and
they had come up with a range of tools
to
analyze complex systems and so i looked
at that and i looked at complex systems
that is really interesting now before we
look at that a complex system here is
not understood as
a complicated system something that
seems chaotic
it's it's complex in the mathematical
sense a complex system that copied that
out of a textbook
is made up made out of many
non-identical elements
connected by diverse interactions now i
think the important part here is
many so you have many elements
and interactions you have many elements
that interact one and with one another
the simplest complex system that i can
think of
came out of physics is called the spin
glass model and it's used to model
ferromagnets so if you have a magnet you
know that the magnetism comes out of the
little spins on the electron basis and
i'm getting a deficient territory as you
can tell
but the the basic idea is you have these
spins and if you want to model a magnet
and understand
what state a magnet ends up with you
model it as a spin glass which is a
lattice
a particular type of graph a regular
graph a lattice is a
structural regular graph of individual
spins that have a binary state
and the interactions are repulsions
between those spins that are opposite to
one another
so it's super super simple if you think
about it you just have one type of
element a spin
and you have just one type of
interaction which is repulsion in case
that the two spins are non-identical
yet the system itself exhibits very very
complex behavior and it's
it's it's extremely difficult to predict
the ultimate state that a ferromagnet
will end up with
right and so it was this class of
problems that people became suddenly
much more interested in because we had
the data available
and the way that people were looking at
those problems is by looking at the data
and some of those classes are social
networks or biological systems as i said
and tried to figure out can we
understand
those systems now importantly the
difference here is they weren't trying
to force the complex systems into some
type of representation that was more
amenable to analysis
they took the complex systems as is and
went to town with it and that's
something that
as a computer scientist i was kind of
adverse to right we don't really like
complexity all that much i mean we try
to avoid it wherever we can
and in the programs that we try to write
we try to get rid of complexity as much
as we possibly can
yet here was a discipline that went out
and said hey we're going to embrace
complexity and
and really try to make sense of our
reality but looking at it as a complex
system
to sort of further go into what we mean
by complex systems i think we have some
really
really fascinating examples that that we
can look at today
one of which are our social networks we
now have a lot more data about how
humans interact
right i mean we have facebook for
instance which has i think more than a
billion people now
and a ton of interactions between those
people that allow us to study it but
even before that we had numerous other
social networks like
like like the flickr social network
which is partly available as open source
um that we could look at and we were
able to uncover some quite fascinating
relationships about
society as a whole for instance um one
of the things that we always thought
for many decades in fact is that these
kinds of networks that arise and here's
a visualization of the facebook social
network
and the the arts indicating friendships
between people that they were
pretty random right that those were
random networks more or less the
connections between
followed followed a gaussian
distribution the degree distribution
it turns out however that that is not
the case in fact that networks of all
sorts and flavors
follow a power law degree distribution a
power law degree distribution what that
means is that
when you look when you when you plot the
number of vertices by their degree
that follows a power law which is a
heavy tail distribution
you might have seen also you might have
heard the term zipfian distribution
which is used in nlp quite a lot to
model the distribution of
words so that was really interesting
that we have these few
vertices or nodes in these networks that
are highly connected then a lot of nodes
that are loosely connected
but what turns out that that is not just
a coincidence because these networks
tend to be extremely
robust against interference if you
randomly interfere with such a network
if you randomly pull out nodes
you don't tend to disturb the network
very much
now why would that matter well it
matters for social networks when you
look at information diffusion if you
have a society and you want to broadcast
information
then it's good that it's robust again
these kinds of interferences
because if you have a regime that
doesn't like you to broadcast these
messages it makes it harder for that
regime to interfere with your activities
it's also interesting for the net for
the internet that we all rely on
it it actually follows that very same
distribution which is kind of funny
right if you think about it you have a
social network on the one hand you have
the internet on the other hand
yet at the core if you if you
mathematically take it apart
they look very similar they also have
that robustness built in given by the
power law distribution which is good for
the internet because it means if i take
out a random server
it doesn't disrupt the internet all that
much and in fact you probably won't even
notice
so we have the internet as a complex
system sorry social networks as a
complex system that we can analyze
biology is another fascinating area
where complex systems are becoming much
much more important as we move on
because as we study the human system
it's really it's one of the most
fascinating complex systems you can
think of right we're all made out of
individual cells
right those are like teeny tiny if i put
them on a table in a cell
you couldn't possibly imagine that that
you could build a human out of that
thing
right you take billions and billions of
those put them together and suddenly bam
here comes
human which is called a phenomenon that
is called
emergence when you have many systems
that when put together by way of their
complex interactions
exhibit a new behavior that is called
that phenomenon is called emergence and
it's something that is unique to complex
systems
and something that that i think is quite
fascinating because
if we try to avoid complexity where we
can what we essentially end up doing is
we avoid
emergence we avoid the phenomena of
emergence emergence that also happens in
social networks if you look at
the arak spring for example you know
there there's some indication that that
twitter
played a role in that which is a role
that emerged
on top of that communication platform
that they built probably not foreseen
that it could ever have that impact
biological systems
are no different in that if you look at
you know the human body most of the
diseases that we are faced with today
can no longer be easily solved by
developing a drug that just
targets one particular spot in your body
if you look for instance that cancer
if you look at hiv those are highly
highly diverse diseases
that require a holistic system analysis
in order to understand
how to tackle them and that in turn
requires us to analyze and understand
complex systems
and lastly the financial system i think
we have we've had a very
uh vivid demonstration of what happens
when you don't understand complex
systems
you know that happened in in 2009 when
the financial system was on the risk of
collapse
and nobody really had a clue what the
hell was going on the reason that was
the case is because we did not and at
that time
didn't try to understand the
complexities of these different
financial dependencies between the
institutions
and therefore had no idea what was going
to happen when one of those
collapsed again pointing to the fact
that complex systems
are extremely important for us to
understand and analyze
and while we try to get away from
complexity where we can
i think a much more interesting approach
is now to actually embrace it where we
find it
so that we can exploit it and build
really cool systems and solve really
cool problems
in the process so putting the two
together
i got really interested into enabling
humans to analyze complex systems
by the very nature that is you know
they're complex so we need the good
tools in the process to give humans the
power to actually look into them
and make and derive conclusions how
would we fight a particular
disease how can we structure our society
so people are happier how can we build
our financial systems
so that they're not so volatile all
these questions i think are imminently
important
and they can only be solved if we look
at the complex systems that underlie
them
now the thing is though we don't really
have a whole lot of good tools
right we we don't have a lot of good
tools to analyze these complex systems
and that's why we went down the journey
of building some
and that is called one of the tools i
want to talk about is called
titan which is a distributed graph
database it's part of a larger stack
called the aurelius graph cluster
and what we're trying to do is we're
trying to build a holistic ecosystem of
tools that allow you to tackle these
types of problems
as i've hopefully managed to do by now
is to
at least convince you somewhat that
graphs are really useful
one for representing information in a
way that is natural for humans but two
also
to represent complex systems because by
their very nature
we have many elements that interact by a
set of diverse interactions
which is exactly what a graph is good at
representing right so graphs
seem to be a fundamentally important
data structure we
i don't think they're given a lot of uh
i don't think they're given a big role
in our education but i hope
that that is going to change and if you
take anything away from this talk and
ignoring anything i'm going to say
later is really that point of graphs
looking at graphs and trying to figure
out if graphs could become
part of your day-to-day toolbox i think
if we want to solve these problems
graphs need to become
as natural to us are as as hash maps we
use hash maps on a daily basis we don't
really think much about them we know
when to use them and what they're good
for
for graphs that is not so easy maybe
just because we're not familiar with
them but hopefully we'll get to that
point
and you will be able to use them just
like you currently use a hash map
now one particular implementation of
this hash map or particular information
graph is titanium there are many others
and i encourage you to check them out
but i'm going to talk
a little more about titan and the
distributed graph database
titan itself was is inspired a great
deal
by the most amazing graph computer
that i know of and that that is the
human brain right it's the only graph
computer that we know if that
actually natively runs on hardware that
is amenable to graph computing
so we're kind of at a disadvantage as
computer science is trying to build
a graph based system because our
hardware is essentially sequential right
we're still
very close to the original turing
machine is that we have this one big
long tape
now the tape is you know partly in the
level of caches partly in ram and partly
on this
but it's still pretty much sequential
and doesn't have that connectedness
property that our brain has
but still i think we can make a good
good attempt at that and with with titan
we're trying to do that
titan partly tries to get around that
that problem of of
sequentiality that our phenomena
architecture imposes on us but
representing grass in an adjacency list
format
but there are three things that really
differentiate titan
from other systems that i know of
that are inspired by how the brain works
i want to talk about these three the
first is our brain
is a highly concurrent distributed
system
it's quite amazing how that works we're
not consciously aware of that
which is even more amazing but at any
point in time you have many many
processes that concurrently
happen in your brain and while most of
your brain is effectively
at sleep meaning not literally sleeping
but not
active right and so in building
a graph database we felt like one of the
things that we needed to build in from
the get-go
was that ability to be highly concurrent
and highly distributed
now we benefited greatly here from the
event of of
no sql which was you know really
concerned with building distributed
architectures that were fundamentally
scalable so we just
write piggyback on top of that using
cassandra apache cassandra and apache
hbase to build titan on top of
but there are some unique challenges to
building graph database and one is that
it's not quite so trivial how you want
to partition your data
how would you assign a graph to the
individual machines in a cluster
right how do you coerce a graph into
rows and columns which is ultimately the
bigtable
data model that you have now we said
we're going to use a
adjacency list representation that's one
thing but it still doesn't answer the
question for how do you assign the
individual vertices to individual
machines
that is a problem that is called graph
partitioning
and it's quite amazing how our brain
does that
it was long thought that the the
different parts of our brain was was
sort of had fixed assignment that there
was this motor brain and that there was
the visual cortex
and that basically that's how it went
right that's how the brain
by your genetic code would ever
represent you know it's it's
ever allocated computing resources now
it turned out though that when people
looked at blind people
that it's it's not true that their
visual cortex was just
sitting there not doing anything because
obviously you know since they were blind
it didn't have any input
it actually turned out that the brain
reallocated those computing resources
to other sensory systems and therefore
blind people have much
better sense much better senses when it
comes for instance to touch or smell
now that is quite fascinating how does
the brain do that it seems to indicate
that we don't have in it genetically
encoded the way that we that the brain
partitions its resources
but that there's some way of figuring
out and in other words that's something
that we needed to do
with titan as well is some way of
figuring out how to allocate
the particular machine resources to
particular types of parts of the graph
such that we still balance out overall
the computational resources
so that we don't have hot spots in our
system now it's a problem that
by no means i'm claiming to have solved
because it's quite challenging to do
when you have a real-time system that
receives
updates all the time right you don't you
never have a static view of the graph
that you can then go to town on and say
i'm going to cut this up in this way and
then store it on these machines so
approach that we take
is is a mixture of existing partitioning
algorithms and we
have used label propagation most
effectively to solve that problem
but combine it with an innate
understanding of how the graph works at
the data model and
allow titan to give it hints so that it
knows how to chunk up its data
and then use automatic methods like
label propagation to fine tune the
partitioning
and we found that to be a very effective
solution to solving this problem
and just hope to do much more research
along those lines to come up
with brain inspired petitioning
algorithms
another thing that our brain does quite
amazingly well
is figuring out what is relevant or not
i mean at any given second you're
bombarded with tons of information
and our brain seems to filter them out
pretty well so that you focus on the
most relevant ones
more amazingly even though you might
temporarily consume a lot of information
over time it seems that only the most
relevant stuff
survives if you look at neuroscience
people say well you know the things that
fire together wire together so the
things that you frequently use get
connected
and the connection gets stronger over
time as you use them and that's i think
a very important
principle but there's also this
principle of weighing or relevance
or as jeff hawkins wrote in his book the
brain has a strong sense of
sequence of time sequence time is a very
important dimension for us humans we
think of things as they occur
sequentially over time
but we tend to order a lot of other
things as well so that notion of
ordering in a graph is important and
one way that titan incorporates that is
by the by the notion of a vertex centric
index now what does that mean when you
look at a vertex in the graph you have
all these incoming and outgoing edges
that connectors are shown in this
picture here
now typically if you know a lot of
typically the way it would represent
them is you
look at all edges and create them equal
right and so then when you retrieve it
you have to go over all these edges
they're all equal so you have to iterate
over them and
then figure out which of these edges are
actually meaningful to you
what titan allows you to do it allows
you to specify
certain relevance criterion by which you
want to order those edges
and then index them accordingly so that
you can
say things like give me the edges that
have
the 10 edges that have the highest
timestamp time
again being a very important dimension
here by which you would order those
edges
right and titan will then lay out the
data in the underlying storage backend
so that it can efficiently retrieve only
those edges that you're actually asking
for
all right another way in which we enable
or in
which we build titan that is inspired by
the brain and turns out that that is
fundamentally important when you look at
scalable systems because as the amount
of data increases
each vertex the degree of each vertex
means the number of edges also increases
and so you quickly run out of space and
out of computational resources and
things just slow down a lot if you don't
have these index structures
and finally one of the things that our
brain does amazingly well as well
is that subconscious thinking
now you think when you sleep your brain
is asleep that turns out to be false in
fact our brain is anything but asleep
when we sleep it does a very important
job and that is organizing our brain
you receive a lot of information during
the day and at night your brain goes to
town on that information
trying to sort it into what you already
know in order to make sense of your
world
what i'm trying to do today really is to
implant in you that idea that grafts are
important so that when you go to sleep
tonight
it's going to subconsciously eat you up
from the inside and then you wake up to
morning like man i should learn more
about grass that's really what this talk
is all about
but that notion of real time processing
which we all are aware of that's our
day-to-day thinking that's how we go
about the world but also the
subconscious the lingering thought
i think is a very important analogy for
computing as well
we have titan which is a real-time
system that answers real-time
queries that you have you know for your
day-to-day applications or operations
but then we also built faunas which is
in a way titan's brother
and responsible for analytic type
processing the type of lingering thought
when you try to
analyze or rearrange your data it
operates directly on titan
and in fact uses the same query language
gremlin that i showed you so the way
that you think about the data is the
same
but the process behind it is different
one is real time the other is batch
one is oltp the other is olap but both
of them are married together
in an approach that is tightly
integrated you don't see any etl
pipeline going on here
right so so the the important aspect
here being putting those two together
so you can build applications to take
advantage of both your real-time
thinking
but also that lingering thought the
analytics what drives
a lot of the analytics processing and
marry them in one coherent system
so that basically concludes a rough the
rough overview of titan and faunus um
all of this is released as apache too so
you're happy to check it out
and play around with it it's still very
young we're actively developing on it
there are lots and lots of very
interesting questions that are still
open
and not solved and um you know we
you know would very much appreciate any
input from the community or any help you
want to offer here
um to build those i think it's a
fascinating area there are lots of
really cool questions that you can solve
or address with this
and i yeah i hope you get the time to
check them out
thank you